I'll make this very quick I asked for
just a minute or two to talk to you
about Numb focus yesterday you heard
from Jim and Gina about what numb focus
is as an organization what I wanted to
talk to you about what my role within
them focus is and what your role within
them focus is so I'm here representing
them focus now focus is a 501c3
nonprofit that helps organize pileated
conferences throughout the world I serve
as vice president numb focus but in the
end all I am is a volunteer what
happened was four years ago or five
years ago or maybe six years ago I lose
track of time I I spoke at the very
first Pi Day event in New York City and
I really liked the crowd I really liked
giving a talk I got a lot of positive
feelings from that and so when we held
an event in Boston I when I spoke in
Boston and when pie Dida came back to
New York they were looking for people to
sit on a proposal selection committee I
had spoken before they sent me an email
and I sat on the committee and I like
pied enough that I kept attending events
I wanted to help out I wanted to do
something to build more events like that
and that's all it took and so every
single one of you sitting here in the
audience you have the ability to be a
volunteer just like myself just like Ian
just like emmalin and all it takes is a
desire to want to build a kind of
community that you've seen over this
last these past few days the energy to
do that and the anion the principles and
values of them focus and the open source
scientific computing community every
single one of you and I can tell you
some very specific things that you can
do to make that happen we want them
focus to be represented and we want pie
data to be represented at every event
throughout Europe however it's very
difficult to to bring me over to bring
Jim or Gina over to all these events we
have an ambassadorship program this is
an opportunity for you to go to an event
to represent them focus to give out
stickers to get a free ticket we helped
offset some travel it's an opportunity
for you to represent what you see at
this event at other events throughout
Europe and so if that's something you're
interested in please come speak to me or
speak to Jim afterwards or speak to Gina
additionally I know this conference is
looking for volunteers next year I know
the meetup here is looking for
volunteers if you want to be a part of
what's going on here talk to Cecilia
talk to Marco talk to Florian they'll
tell you how you can get more involved
because Cecilia Marco and Florian
started like
volunteers like anybody else they said
I'm willing to help out I have that
energy I have that drive and we're good
people with the right principles and now
you can see them chairing this amazing
event so I just wanted to let you know
that that's possible I wanted to give
you that message and I want you to think
about that because these communities
only exist on the back of the hard work
of the volunteers behind them but there
is no barrier to becoming a volunteer
anybody can do it it just takes those
three things a little bit of time and
energy and a willingness to promote the
kind of community the kind of good
values that you see here over the last
few days so thank you so much I'm Neil
Stoker and just want to very briefly
mention about PyCon UK so if anyone
doesn't know what it is it's kind of in
the name but it's it's a volunteer
conference very much like this one and
PyCon UK this year is gonna be in
Cardiff September the 15th it's a
five-day conference so I echoing what
James said I also sort of got involved
in the same kind of way as a volunteer
we're all volunteers in PyCon UK as well
we're 700 we have about 700 conference
attendees and it's it's just opened its
call for proposals so if you if you've
got a talk that you'll be dying to give
I'm sure pi days would love to hear it
but also we would love to consider you
as well
so do do please think about submitting
for talks if you'd like to buy tickets
tickets are on sale now as well and yeah
there's a few there's a few other
benefits all go through very quickly
we've we've got poster sessions so we've
got people presenting research we've got
sprints as well we have a free creche
which delighted to see that pie data had
also got one we've tried that out last
year and it's really really effective
we're keen to make sure that people can
come to the conference and there's no
barriers for them coming along if
they've got family commitments or
anything like that so so we are really
trying to make sure that it can be as
inclusive as possible so the way to find
out about more about it is on the
website
so it's the the URL is 2018 dot pi
so it's top icon UK dog
save them please check it out and
hopefully same thought I just wondered
well you probably saw me yesterday here
talking about the pandas Springs I'm
going to talk about the pandas
experience again but what I'm going to
talk today is the Panda this means that
we've got these this morning just to
give a better idea on what it what it is
I know that many of you wanted to come
but actually wanted to go to the dogs I
think that all were really really good
this year and was difficult to compete
with that but we still managed to have
22 people what we were working on mainly
was in some pages in the documentation
of of pandas namely it's been people
mainly working on well I don't think you
can see much but in in the STR module
like things like it slides that feel
repeat match operations with the strings
in a serious and also we some other some
other interesting ticket like a
splitting test that at the end actually
some other people was working on that
already I'm fixing some confusion on the
documentation that it was some comments
that were misleading and that the whole
goal in the documentation part was
converting documentation like this this
is the kernel density estimate
documentation it basically says that
it's a kernel density estimate plot it's
quite useful and I did it get some
keyword arguments it's give arguments
passed to the plot it's in the future
version of pandas it's in the in the
Travis CI so far it was actually
something from another yeah they'd like
more like a long description and like
the parameters are well documented now
also some see also functions like the
equivalents I hope you compute that the
equivalent serious plot API and some
examples with a with eggs lodge that
what a spring is about just some people
gathering together to work in the dog
string in this case and unfixed is a
stack some other times it bursts box
what some some good work done we got so
far so I get takes a decent amount of
time and we got so far this to pull
requests already waiting for for
reviewers I think it will be like three
for more coming up in the next hours
when the rest of the people in the
spring is able to finish what they were
doing
I think people learned a lot they had
fun you can check a v8 what was going on
in the in the sprint in there just like
the people the pill coding and you keep
scrolling you can find like the people
well I don't know yeah if you keep going
down you can see like so many more going
down you can see like pictures in the
Indic oh yeah it was in Bratislava and
here it is like the places where people
like some plot on what happened the
spring day in the get rape or this worst
Chicago and well it's quite an
interesting threat even if your skin
need to skip a bit of Hispanic people
tweeting pandas or whatever it was that
and yeah if you're interested I already
spoke to some of you especially the ones
that are not in London if you're in
London feel free to join us Prince any
time we are keeping them like every
other week or so if you're not in London
and you're interested in analyzing a
spring in your local community and you
need some advice
feel free to contact me that's like my
my profile you can find me on the
internet in the database on insta can
contact me on LinkedIn Twitter whatever
I'll try to help as much as possible now
Chuck will will explain like what was
the experience from like a participant
point of view thanks okay so yeah this
is my pool request so you can see that I
already submitted my pool request to a
tostring it doesn't go through one of
the test
it's the continuous test but I think
yeah it's just well that's the thing
like actually months ago I didn't even
do a pull request I don't know like I
mean I used get but like I'm always like
Messi and I don't know like how to
collaborate with people because I don't
even like I do everything on master
which is horrible
so I learned a lot actually I learned a
lot
from going to the plant Python spring so
yeah actually you may think that like oh
just the dog strains just documentation
not technical but yeah actually I can
show you maybe um yeah okay I will show
you what I did today
yeah fire yeah so yeah actually a
documentation could be like I would say
that oh it's too small no okay
I'll just talk about it and okay yeah
actually like for example this example
how to find a meaning for example and
also clearly explaining what this method
too is kind of tricky it's like I would
say that it's like an art like you need
to there's some creativity in it like
for example with the animal I make some
examples so it's like you know it's a
particle order and things like that so
yeah there's some some creativity in a
so don't don't feel like always boring
just documentation no it's not as fun so
I recommend everybody try to come to the
spring as well so if we look at the
London Python spring there is I believe
that's two event coming up yeah so next
Tuesday we'll have one that is alpha
gender minority community so if you feel
that if you go to a meet-up or go to a
conference that is like you feel a bit
you know nervous like don't worry like
with this friends there will be mainly
you know gender minority people so
because we encourage you to join the
community so this is especially for you
to start to get started and we will help
you to can learn how to make a few
requests and then after that you can
join the event on the a which is yeah
which is the spring for yeah
the don't your way I don't know like
mark you need to explain ways to do it
your way
maybe yeah so yeah I encourage you to
join the event so look us up on Meetup
and yeah thank you
[Applause]
so and myself and a very brave bunch of
volunteers just met the last two hours
and bashing our heads against the world
of political day to an open election
data in in a room just few minutes away
so the whole problem here is we had a
few different strands of essential work
the volunteers could do yes one was
liberating polling data so polling data
is a nightmare to work with
it's open but by open I mean it's free
to download free to share maybe we don't
know the licenses are but stuck in a PDF
table it's a very common open data
formats and there's a lot of information
in polling data not just headlined
voting attention who you going to vote
for the next election but what's your
age what's your demographic what's your
level of education where do you live
what region none of this is ever
analyzed you've got instead of just the
five numbers that get published onto a
front-page news story there's like five
hundred numbers to be analyzed and dug
into in every single poll and there's
maybe during an election like three
polls every single day so if we can just
get this data out this would be
incredible for just analyst analysis so
one group of people try to get data out
this is a first attempt not great
the final attempt after two and a half
hours of work was using a non
open-source tool SSAS product to get it
into a nice-looking Excel document still
not a dataframe
and still a lot of work to be done
getting that headline voting intention
out and this is maybe page one out of 30
pages as an entire panel people them
just figure out which page is the one
that contains the data you want so
hugely difficult problem but some
interesting new strands of how you might
tackle this AI has so much further to go
when it comes to but publishing and
scraping data so if this is something
you're interested in here's some
recommendations tabular PDF tables and
able to abstract as a paid-for tool what
can you do if you had this data we can
do things like regional polling and
regional kind of preferences and
sentiment Wales and Northern Ireland
that's got and got very excited when I
started doing this and the general
last year because no one had ever
generated one of these sort of you know
how the Conservatives doing in Scotland
especially not in Northern Ireland so
they got very excited when we started
releasing this imagine what else we
could do if we could just liberate all
its information
another fastness john was predicting
local elections we have a local
elections next week in england and all
of that data is again in so many
different places so those sort of a team
of people trying to pull out that data
work with it and again two and a half
hours later so far away from a
prediction model they're able to at
least visualize some historical results
from the last election so in this is
using I think some geo pandas and some
visualization using corabeth's of
conservative labour greens and Lib Dems
their vote share in London just on
council local elections and then final
strand was predicting general elections
this is like the headline winner if you
can predict a general election in the UK
people stopped paying interest to you so
this was a big fan of work for me last
year and we put out prediction that the
Conservatives to get a majority of 22
now we all know that that didn't happen
there were nine short of a majority so
how did the people who work on the
general election in the hackathon over
the last few hours do given all of my
work given all of my model ready data
that's given seven weeks of my blood
sweat and tears the best model wasn't
off-the-shelf copies just literally
swept out gradient boosting and
scikit-learn swap in cat beast and
suddenly you get that majority down a
little bit further it still a majority
of twenty but if only we had things like
demographics and census information
feeding into the model which we didn't
even have because it's hard to get that
data in in the first place it's stuck in
strange places like the NHS Camden
archive website why is open data about
our census Stock Exchange archived
websites I would love to know and how
does that compare to the other forecasts
that were published by the people who do
this for a living and it's still better
than any other forecast using open data
and so yes in in like two hours someone
managed to build a better model than
anyone did last year and summary over
two and a half hours of hacking around
with data and this is a phrase from
someone said Maisie I spend all my time
just looking error messages and
and a half hours is a great amount of
time to get a taster for subjects but if
you want to do this please talk to me
and find me 650 data on Twitter thank
you very much people try to get data
this is a first attempt not great
the final attempt after two and a half
hours of work was using a non
open-source tool SS SAS product to get
it into a nice-looking Excel document
still not a dataframe and still a lot of
work to be done getting that headline
boasting intention out and this is maybe
page one out of 30 pages as an entire
animal people them just for out figure
out which page is the one that contains
the data you want so hugely difficult
problem but some interesting new strands
of how you might tackle this AI has so
much further to go when it comes to best
publishing and scraping data so if this
is something you're interested in here's
some recommendations tabular PDF tables
and able to abstract as a paid-for tool
what can you do if you had this data we
can do things like regional polling and
regional kind of preferences and
sentiment whales and all hi everyone I'm
Luhan
I am computer science undergraduate
student from India and I work in machine
using machine learning for astronomy and
for the last two months I have been
working with the lovely astronomers at
the University of Southampton whose
names I mentioned there to try and use
it to solve a problem in their domain
which is x-ray astronomy so what we were
trying to do is to classify black holes
and neutron stars in binary systems so
just to start off binary systems for
those who might not know are basically
two stars orbiting around each other and
I've got a nice visualization to show
you so this is something which I found
on the internet creates to the guy who
made it and this is essentially an x-ray
binary system so what happens is in when
you're when among the two of your stars
one star is a neutron star or a black
hole it's a very compact object and
has lots of gravity to it and as you can
see is a creating matter from the normal
companion star and it's the glowing
thing in the center of the disk so what
we would like to do is try to figure out
given a source whether the thing in the
middle is a black hole or a neutron star
so and why we want to do that because
the traditional methods in this domain
are very unreliable in the sense that
the they include either calculating mass
which is very very difficult or you look
for something called pulsations which
are existent only neutron stars but if
you don't find pulsations they can the
source can either be a neutron star or a
black hole it can still be a non
advancing neutron star source so you can
imagine that and sometimes it involves
watching the source for a long period of
time of about weeks or months before we
have any clue about its class and this
can get really inconvenient and
expensive imagine waiting six months
thinking you're going to see a neutron
star and realizing oh that's a black
hole and it sucks so so then I need of
the R is definitely to create some
automatic classifiers which can help
astronomers track these objects
instantly if possible and you know if
they want to study neutral so they
should be immersed in time with that so
let's look at the data that we had so
each so as you can see we had some 8300
neutron star observations and some sorry
yeah and some 7,000 dot black hole
observations these data are essentially
energy versus counts which is since most
of the data is generated in x-rays the
energy we calculate how much in a how
many photons arrive with a particular
energy and so we had a fairly balanced
data set so we didn't have to worry
about that and then we chose random
forest classifier which seemed to
perform the best for this and drumrolls
will it does pretty well it classified
it has an accuracy of 95% and these are
the statistics I don't know if you can
see but so it it if you can see the
precision recall and f1 scores for both
the classes are consistent which means
which indicates that it should be doing
a good job and to further see if does so
we look at the predicted probabilities
for each observation which you can see
so the x-axis is predicted probability
0.2 0.4 0.6 0.1 and y-axis is a number
of observations which were predicted
with that probability so as you can see
most of the observations were predicted
correctly and with fair amount of
confidence they were very confident they
know what they're talking about and the
same trend was observed with black holes
so yeah we well here's the thing we use
basic machine learning to solve a
problem in astronomy that was initially
very complex and to solve using standard
methods and really painful thing but
here's the interesting part that data
being collected and Astronomy cursor vus
is increasing and going to a point where
surveys like LSST and sk will generate
data in several petabytes per night so
that makes it one of the most extreme
data science Big Data projects I think
to have ever taken place and this is
leading to a very new field of study
research called
Astro informatics which is not a made-up
word and I know because astronomers and
they say so you are are you interested
in a strong informatics and they say
what is that so
they think that it's something I made up
so you know it's not a made up word and
astronomy is going to need a lot more
data science in the coming years and I
think a lot of us can learn from
industrial expertise which can be used
to make sense out of the petabytes of
data that the future holds so if you are
interested in this I would love to talk
to you you can find me after the
lightning talks and thank you for some
8300 neutron star observations and some
sorry yeah and some 7,000 dot black hole
observations these data are essentially
energy versus counts which is since most
of the data is generated in x-rays the
energy we calculate how much in a how
many photons arrive with a particular
energy and so we had a fairly balanced
data set so we didn't have to worry
about that and then we chose random
forest classifier which seemed to
perform the best for this and drumrolls
will it does pretty well it classified
it has an accuracy of 95% and these are
the statistics I don't know if you can
see but so it it if you can see the
precision recall and f1 scores for both
the classes are consistent which means
which indicates that it should be doing
a good job and to further at PI data I
like talking about Jupiter workflows
tricks and tips and today is not an
exception I'm going to talk about
Jupiter projects so I want today what I
want you to remember is Jupiter's
project called binder hub used to be
called binder it's a relatively new
project and I'll give you a use case so
let's say you build a node
you built a notebook in your particular
environment let's say Python to Python 3
or R and you want to share it and you
want somebody else to actually run it
and experience running it so that
they're able to step through see the
results modify the results
how do you do it otherwise alright so at
the at the moment you can share static
notebooks on github but they're as good
as static so enter binder hub so we're
gonna do a live demo what could go wrong
ok so I've got some hope you can see the
hyperlinks bitly so I'm gonna click on
this one while it launches and in the
meanwhile I'll explain what's going on
on the so binder hub I'll talk about the
project is the project by Jupiter
organization and in sponsored by the
Moore Foundation essentially the
foundation Provan provides the grant to
[Music]
have the infrastructure in place that
includes the CPU power so you can see
all these funding you can see that what
the what binder hub provides is not only
the infrastructure but also the hardware
so use their CPUs and we can have a look
at some of the stats so for instance you
see the overview so I think they have
about 100 cores so there are there are
always quite a few depositors running ok
still says launching server well live
presentation what could go wrong we can
see the activity of the binder hub you
see by pod bye-bye node and I'm waiting
my project to load to show you
this project is so it's it's a simple
github repo which contains the
definition of environment how you want
to run it and some notebooks so if you
look here so this is so this is supposed
to be a demo where you get launched here
we go right okay so now I have a running
environment so this does not run on my
machine this runs on the CPU like on
cores provided by Moore foundation so
what we can do is we can go ahead and
open let's say CAD boost demo so CAD
boost has been talked about a lot this
time so what we can do is you can see
this is a notebook and this notebook is
long if I can go ahead and run it okay
and cool things happen so you the same
way you can create a repository you can
you can save your notebook committed to
github or bitbucket and you can share it
with someone else and say well look I
mean this is what I've done
feel free to modify it and look this
notebook is live just to show you this
is the cat boost widget you can see the
model is being is being trained it's
it's live okay and you of course you
have IPAM widgets which you can which
you can use and stuff happen so this is
a live notebook and this is all i want
you to remember is binder hub is the way
to share live notebooks with colleagues
especially if you want to if you work on
open source projects if you want to set
it up locally it's possible but the
setup is quite complicated and some
examples and links
you can find them and thank you have the
infrastructure in place that includes
the CPU power so you can see all these
funding you can see that launching what
the what binder hub provides is not only
the infrastructure but also the hardware
so use their CPUs and we can have a look
at some of their stats
so for instance you see the overview so
I think they have about 100 cores so
there are there are always quite a few
very positive running ok still says
launching server well live presentation
what could go wrong we can see the
activity of the binder hub you see
bye-bye pod bye-bye node and I'm waiting
my project to load to show you ok
so anybody who seemed to talk for me
before will see that I know me to throw
myself as a data scientist and
recovering astrophysicist and yesterday
I fell off the wagon so I have to make a
caveat I saw something really cool
yesterday and it's Eric tolerance work
it's his notebook it's all his stuff but
he's not here so I'm gonna present it
but I would encourage you to look at his
Twitter and retweet it if you like what
you're about to see so anybody some of
you may have heard if you're in any way
astronomy nerds about the Gaia mission
it's been up for a number of years and
it's now sending out data the goal of
this mission is to measure the location
distance of 1% of all the stars in our
galaxy that is approximately 1.3 billion
stars we did one of the hardest things
to know about in the universe is how far
away something is and so this in our
galaxy is unprecedented stuff
and oh sorry and last week they did data
released - and they said they have
released 1.3 billion star positions
after a few years with the data in
multiple bands they've got the movement
the radial velocities the proper motions
all this stuff really cool there's more
data than you could wave a stick at for
those who don't know what parallax is
it's this it's when you move the
apparent position of an object also
shifts you know think about it is when
you blink one eye from the other eye
things seem to move back and forth
that's effective parallax you've got two
positions and we move we move around the
Sun so all the stars move but the stars
are very far away so they don't move
very much which is why this is really
hard to do we talk about micro arcsecond
precision for these measurements of how
far the stars are shaped and we they've
done it for 1.3 billion of them but what
that means is you can do really cool
visualizations and what you're about to
see was all done inside of Egypt in
Auckland and he shared the notebook free
for anybody to use as a tutorial or
anything else he's like open license
there and what he's done is he's moved
to make this visible he's moved the
earth from being one astronomical unit 8
light minutes away to pretending it's
one light year away from the Sun in
order to get the wobbles to be big
enough that you can see but what and
what you can see is oh that's nice and
smooth that's the orbital motion what
you can then do is actually throw in the
proper motion and start running time
forward and that's what the Stars are
doing around us
I like I say go find the the tweet i
retweeted it two days ago
go find there go play with a notebook it
it showed you even how to download and
pull all the data it's all being run
locally that was just built in like 15
minutes this afternoon so okay so
anybody who seem to talk for me before
will see that I know me to throw myself
as a data scientist and recovering
astrophysicist and yesterday I fell off
the wagon so I have to make a caveat
here I saw something really cool
yesterday and it's Eric tolerance work
it's his notebook it's all his stuff but
he's not here so I'm gonna tell her my
name is Mattie Lyra I am one of the
organizers for pi Dana Berlin and I was
about to give a talk about a whole kind
of spiel or how we started our ticket
sales and I can fake the statistics so I
can download the data and then do all
kinds of weird time differencing and
averaging to make it look like we're
gonna be a 2,000 press conference and
then say that well we're probably gonna
need a bigger event venue but then I
decided not to do that
and instead talk about something much
more important
myself so what so you hear often this
term being thrown around community and
this sort of connects to what James was
saying earlier oh no he left oh there is
he's a shifty bugger so this is this is
often what you see when you think of PI
data or non focus
it's a Conda install it's a pip install
it's a website but this is the wrong way
I think to think about it because this
is not a community I used to be a PhD
student and this went into my PhD thesis
because all of the work that went into
that relies on the work that these
people did and that was made available
to me at no cost and then along the way
I've sort of accidentally become the
organizer of a potato Berlin and met all
of these people and they're the
loveliest people that you could ever
talk to that's what community means it's
when you come to the conference and you
see the core developer for this library
or the maintainer of that library you
just go talk to them and they'll happily
help you and I don't know maybe solve
your problem maybe you can solve their
problem maybe you can help them so I
want to encourage everyone here as James
did earlier to sort of help us make the
community better we and I believe I'm
speaking on behalf of the pilot London
organizers and well Vincent left but
also Amsterdam Budapest and all the rest
we do this for you we organize these
conferences and the meetups
so that the community has somewhere to
come together we want you to be a part
of that we don't want to be
a website or those organizer people
there that's it yeah well well so the
last the last few lightning talks were
inspirational and honestly this one is
not inspirational this is actually it is
inspirational what I'm about to show you
but not for you for me I'll show you
this is a visitor proper lightning talk
about a proper project that fell between
the cracks and I actually want to finish
but you know I need somebody to help me
get off my butt and finish it and one of
the ways I do that is by giving a talk
and showing it to you and hopefully
getting you excited about the idea and
then maybe maybe that gives me the
impetus to finish it so tell me if this
is a good idea or bad idea
okay this is an idea I had the last time
I came to London this is my lightning
talk and I'm James Powell course you can
follow me on twitter at don't use his
code and it wasn't when I was coming
here for pi day to London it was when I
was going to PI day to Delhi because
it's difficult from New York data
nonstop flight to Delhi and I stopped
through London and I couldn't sleep on
the leg from New York to London so I was
thinking about different ideas and
things that I wanted to do and different
projects and as I was started thinking I
came up with an idea for a game a game
that involved programming in a game that
might be useful in the context of the
communities that we have and the meetups
that we have and I'll tell you a little
bit about the game so a lot of you have
played the game risk it looks kind of
like this you have pieces on the board
you move them around and you conquer
countries and so on and I thought what
if we took that game and we set it in
space and instead of all these risk
units we have spaceships and solar
systems because I don't want to infringe
anyone's copyright too directly and we
put it in real time and we take away the
board and the pieces and instead of that
we have just a JSON API and so for
example you know if you're using HTTP
you might have an HTTP request looks
like this that tells you what is what
are the spaceships in some solar system
and if you want to get the ships you can
kind of look at all the ships that your
enemies have and if you want to look at
some particular system just a very
straightforward JSON API and if you want
to tell the ship to move to some
destination you can put a request to
move it to some destination and I
thought something really interesting
might come out of this because it's a
really simple really low-level API which
means I could take somebody who knows
how to type commands at a console at a
computer but doesn't really know
anything about programming and I give
him a handout with coral or HTTP
commands and they could kind of play
with those right you know they could
look at a command like this and just a
naturally curious person look at that
and wonder well what if I change that
from ship 12 to 23 and they'll see
something happen what if I change the
destination from Mars to Venus and
they'll see something happen and the
interesting thing is in the first 30
minutes just just by oh by rote typing
commands they could move all the ships
around in their fleet from solar system
to solar system they wouldn't have to
know anything but when I type this
command this thing happens but the
interesting thing would happen is what
if we scaled this up very quickly and
around 2 instead of 10 ships you have
100 ships and they might come to me and
say well I can't type a hundred commands
in real-time
and make this work so what I'll tell
them write a bash script so they might
write a simple bash script to run
through all of their commits all of
their ships and to move them around and
I thought well that's kind of
interesting because the API output is
JSON and it doesn't look that great so
when they actually want to play more
competitively they might have to write a
reporting tool and the thing is if they
really want to do something fancy they
might have to write a web front-end and
if they have hundreds of ships moving
around in real time then they might have
to write BOTS and I might have to use AI
they might have to use machine learning
to be competitive at this game but the
thing is as they become more competitive
this game and they want to play against
their friends they want to win it's not
about learning this just for the sake of
learning some theory it's about I have a
very strict thing I want to do what
tools do you give me to use it and one
thing I liked about it is how an idea
like this you start very simple and you
get more complex you can maybe start
introducing quark programming concepts
to newbies in a very very tangible
fashion because they know how to play a
game they know what they need to do then
you know how to come up with strategies
to win that game and they just need to
connect that to the programming tools
that we take for granted that oftentimes
when you're trying to motivate these
topics them
who cares about metaclasses and
decorators and whatnot but they do care
about I have the strategy how do i
implement it oh maybe I need to use this
particular programming technique
so I wanted to try and pursue this as a
motivation to learn programming for them
to improve their programming I think the
idea of approaching programming via
automation is a very easy way to present
a topic like this to an audience that is
technical but not necessarily familiar
with all of the terminology and one
thing I really like it about is that
it's it might be something that's very
practically motivated perfect code
doesn't matter in this game it doesn't
matter you know coming up with the best
theory the best model the most elegant
code there's only one thing that matters
in this case and that one thing is
galactic domination so thank you so much
this is an idea if you liked it let me
know and maybe there's something that we
can do with it this year thank you so
much and so for example you know if
you're using HTTP you might have an HTTP
request that looks like this that tells
you what is what are the spaceships in
some solar system and if you want to get
the ships you can kind of look at all
the ships that your enemies have and if
you want to look at some particular
system just a very straightforward JSON
API and if you want to tell the ship to
move to some destination you can put a
request to move it to some destination
and I thought something really
interesting might come out of this
because it's a really simple really
low-level API which means I could take
somebody who knows how to type commands
at a console or computer but doesn't
really know anything about programming
and I'd give him a hand out with curl or
HTTP commands and they could kind of
play with those right you know they
could look at a command like this and
just a naturally curious person will
look at that and wonder well what if I
change that from ship 12 to 23 and
they'll see something happen what if I
change the destination from Mars to
Venus and they'll see something happen
and the interesting thing is in the
first 30 minutes just just by oh by rote
typing commands they could move all the
ships around in their fleet from solar
system to solar system they wouldn't
have to know anything but when I type
this command this thing happens but the
interesting thing would happen is what
if we scaled this up very quickly and
around 2 instead of 10 ships you have
100 ships and they might come to me and
say well I can't type a hundred commands
in real-time and make this work so what
I'll tell them write a bash script so
they might write a simple bash script to
run through all of their commits all of
their ships and to move them around and
I thought well that's kind of
interesting because the API output is
JSON and it doesn't look that
great so when they actually want to play
more competitively they might have to
write a reporting tool and the thing is
if they really want to do something fast
they might have to write a web front-end
and if they have hundreds of ships
moving around in real time then they
might have to write BOTS and I might
have to use AI they might have to use
machine learning to be competitive at
this game but the thing is as they
become more competitive this game and
they want to play against their friends
they want to win it's not about learning
this just for the sake of learning some
theory it's about I have a very strict
thing I want to do what tools do you
give me to use it and one thing I liked
about it is how an idea like this you
start very simple and you get more
complex you can maybe start introducing
quark programming concepts to newbies in
a very very tangible fashion because
they know how to play a game they know
what they need to do then you know how
to come up with strategies to win that
game and they just need to connect that
to the programming tools that we take
for granted that often times you're
trying to motivate these topics them who
cares about metaclasses and decorators
and whatnot but they do care about I
have the strategy how do i implement it
oh maybe I need to use this particular
programming technique so I wanted to try
and pursue this as a motivation to learn
programming for them to improve their
programming I think the idea of
approaching programming via automation
is a very easy way to present a topic
like this to an audience that is
technical but not necessarily familiar
with all of the terminology and one
thing I really like it about is that
it's it might be something that's very
practically motivated perfect code
doesn't matter in this game it doesn't
matter you know coming up with the best
theory the best model the most elegant
code there's only one thing that matters
in this case and that one thing is
galactic domination so thank you so much
this is an idea if you liked it let me
know and maybe there's something that we
can do with it this year thank you so
much
you